food now turned into waste yet hunger
and food insecurity still plagued the
African continent the UN Food and
Agriculture Organization report for 2016
says about fourteen million people in
Nigeria are hungry or undernourished in
many grocery stores and supermarkets
there were food whose shelf life runs
out before they are consumed because the
purchasing power of the populace is
either not fair or not enough meat Oskar
f-body more who wants to change all that
he has had a difficult spell of living
without enough food before now he and
some friends have even made efforts to
cater to some families food needs he
came up with an idea that's taken that
passion are not higher okay so Chow
berry is a web-based software that
enables that empowers disadvantaged
groups with affordable nutrition and at
the same time helps cut down on food
waste and products that would otherwise
be wasted due to exploration when he was
11 years old
ill health forced his father to stop
work the result was that he and his
siblings sometimes had to go without
food while I was in university I
discovered much later I was about to
finish school that particular
supermarket was throwing away food that
was expiring and I approached them at
the time and they decided to okay we'll
give it to you so how does Chaubey work
to change this for those in need of food
and ensure there's no waste on one hand
the retailer is able to use the
application of software to track and
monitor products that are approaching
the end of shelf-life in an automated
fashion and this absolutely allows him
you know be informed at all times and
take immediate action on photos
approaching the end of shelf-life so the
novelty there is then that while he's
you know analyzing all of that data and
monitoring all of that data that same
data is streamed on a marketplace front
end as deep discount from the moment the
app was launched the visits to the sites
have continued to rise from about 1500
daily
to almost triple that figure the
supermarkets the NGO and low income
earners that have experienced the cherry
app are quite pleased
so we able to go for cure those items
are hugely discounted rate most times
even up to 70 percents discounts and so
with this we are now able to buy more
with less money and less resources we
collect the goods that are almost or
about to expire get it back to your
society you know what it means instead
of letting it go to tally on it every
store safe course a polymer says the
response to the project has been
encouraging an initial three-month pilot
involved 20 retailers that reached about
300 people in Lagos and Abuja and feed
in about a hundred and fifty orphans and
children at risk now he's hoping to
reach a lot more people individually and
collectively through the Chari 2.0 app